imagine the most profound Ice Age you
can think of temperatures plummet to
below zero even at the equator before
long ice encloses our entire planet
research suggests that this may have
happened not once but three times in our
planet's past welcome to snowball earth
a snowball earth is certainly the most
extreme climate change we can conceive
the earth having ever experienced what
would happen if the world froze over
today massive glaciers creep from the
poles crushing everything in their path
first of all the Canadians are gonna
have to dig much deeper holes when they
go ice fishing next the governors of
Washington Idaho Montana North Dakota
Minnesota and Michigan and Maine will
probably declare federal emergencies
cities grind to a halt powerlines
collapse and water supplies freeze cars
won't start roads are cut off by ice
building strain and crumble under deep
drifts of snow
everything is entombed our frail bodies
struggle to survive I think human
society would collapse if a snowball
earth happened again the oceans freeze
over fish die and marine ecosystems
collapse our food supply becomes
exhausted any surviving humans are
trapped in an icy hell it would have a
mass die-off of humans simply because we
could not grow enough food under these
conditions incredible though it may seem
the Earth may have frozen over
completely scientists are finding clues
in unexpected places the story begins
with a mystery in the arid Flinders
Ranges in southern Australia layers of
ancient rock hold unusual stones these
stones are foreign to the area they are
known as drop stones the drop stones are
embedded in an ancient sedimentary sea
floor that formed around 650 million
years ago Tim Robb a geologist at the
California Institute of Technology hunts
for these drop stones at the Flinders
ranged
this is an example the drop stone a
piece of ancient rock that was dropped
into the ancient mud on the sea bottom
these drop stones are visibly different
from the sedimentary bedrock around them
something powerful must have carried
them here but what Dan Schrag professor
of Earth and Planetary Sciences at
Harvard University believes the answer
is glaciers you actually have ice cubes
here that we've made with pieces of sand
and gravel in them so this these ice
cubes are like the glaciers that are
taking rocks from the land and then when
we put them in the water they'll
actually melt and the sand and gravel
will fall to the bottom just like the
drop stones on the ocean floor these
drop stones are evidence that at some
point this area was covered in a thick
layer of ice
[Music]